At the Grind House, Honduran
coffee sells for $8 per pound,
and Costa Rican coffee sells
for $11.50 per pound.
If 1 pound of Central American
Blend coffee contains 0.4
pounds of Costa Rican-- so I did
Costa Rican in this orange
color before, so I'll do it
again-- so it contains 0.4
pounds of Costa Rican coffee
and 0.6 pounds of Honduran
coffee-- I'll do the Honduran
coffee in blue.
That was our original--
that first statement.
How much should 1
pound sell for?
So they're really just saying,
well, how much does it cost
for me to buy 0.4 pounds
of Costa Rican and
0.6 pounds of Honduran?
And if I take that total, that's
how much it's going to
cost me to get 1 pound of my
Central American Blend.
So let's just figure that out.
The Costa Rican coffee-- I'll
write it here-- Costa Rican
coffee-- we're going to--
it's $8 per pound.
Oh no, sorry, it's
$11.50 per pound.
We have to be very careful.
The Costa Rican coffee
is $11.50 per pound.
We can write it like
this, per pound.
And then we're going to multiply
that times the number
of pounds we want of the Costa
Rican coffee in our blend.
And we have 0.4 pounds of it.
So times 0.4 pounds.
The pounds cancel out, and
you have 0.4 times 11.50.
4 times 11.50 would be 44 plus
2, which would be 46, so 0.4
is going to be 4.6.
So this is equal to $4.60.
Now, we'll do the same thing
for the Honduran coffee.
We're going to get 0.6 pounds.
Well, first, let's put
the price here.
It's $8 per pound.
So it is $8 per pound.
And multiply it times the
number of pounds.
We need 0.6 pounds of it.
And 8 times 6 is 48, so
8 times 0.6 is $4.80.
So this is equal to $4.80.
So that's how much we're going
to have to spend on Costa
Rican, that's how much we're
going to have to spend on
Honduran coffee.
If we add them up, that's how
much a pound of the Central
American Blend is going to cost.
Because we're getting--
if you add up the pounds, you
get a pound here, so the total
cost is the total cost of
a pound of the blend.
Let's put it right here.
0 plus 0 is 0.
6 plus 8 is 14.
1 plus 4 plus 4 is 9.
Put the decimal in
the right place.
It's going to cost us a total
of $9.40 for the blend.